this video and charity event is paid for
by seriously seriously I'm serious
how's it going bros my name is spear to
pat i got a new camera
I hope the lens isn't too annoying it's
either focusing on my nose or my ears
it's it's weird you bros were
complaining that there were a little
blemish on the other camera so there you
go besides that I have some very very
important news so this year I'm gonna
participate in race against the slime 2
which is the world's biggest mobile
charity race Jesus Christ ed guy what it
I I hate him basically what this means
is that me marzia and Ken are teaming up
to defeat other youtubers less
good-looking ones and the winners will
get a prize pool to support their
charity so we're all doing this for
charity we decided that the charity that
we want to support is charity water
we've supported them before on this
channel and it's just been one of the
proudest moment of my life because
seeing our community the brows come
together and supporting something that
really matters I would love we've we
came together this Christmas come
together and support charity water once
again because last time we saved one of
their Ugandan projects it really really
did make a difference and to see all the
little comments from the donations that
you bros left it is I was tearing up it
was so cute I'm going to doing it myself
of course I'm pledging 42 thousand US
dollars towards this charity our goal is
to hit a hundred thousand and if we win
the competition we win fifty thousand to
donate towards charity water so we'll
already half way there I highly suggest
that you check out the link in
description and donate towards the
charity also you can download best
fiends in the description and start
defeating the holiday slugs until the
23rd of December if our team defeats
level 23
before the 23rd they will double our
slug count
gives us a better chance to win to see
the standing you can go to best fiends
Facebook page and see who's winning
please support us no one else it is for
charity after all so I guess it
shouldn't be too much of a competition
but damn it we need to win it can get so
grumpy if he loses you have no idea I do
not want to be on the same team at Sam
if we lose so why charity water well
haha think about how easy it is to
access clean water you you put on a tap
and there you go you got drinkable clean
water but imagine if it wasn't so easy
imagine if you had to walk hours away
and then once you finally reach the
water it's not even clean to drink and
people more people die from the diseases
of unclean water than any form of
violence and that includes war there's
also a huge amount of time wasted for
these people to just collect water every
single day it's time that prevents them
from getting an education it's time that
prevents them from taking care of their
families getting a job and for their
communities to fully develop what it
really is the start of everything and it
helps giving these people a chance of
life and that's something that we got
for free and now we we got a chance to
help support that
so Bruce it seems obvious check out the
link donate whatever you have if we can
break the goal I will uh if we can break
the goal I will Electrify my nipples how
about that thank you for being a bro and
supporting this cause check out the link
in description that's all you gotta do
alright breasts I'll see you let's stay
awesome